ces enseignants ne sont pas en train de
jouer c'est manipule des briques de
construction c'est pour penser une
nouvelle façon d'enseigner dans leur
salle de classe avec le numérique
un espace idéal ce serait un espace où
l'enseignant se sent bien au tfc revient
il a envie d'apprendre
mais c'est aussi un espace qui propose
différentes activités vers l'est la
circulation qui permet des temps et des
duels au calme qui permet des temps de
travail en commun entre élèves ou avec
l'enseignant s'adapter aux élèves faire
une pédagogie de projet alors même si on
le répète depuis des années qu est une
impulsion pour que les résultats
s'améliorent et faire que nos élèves
apprennent mieux apprennent avec du
plaisir dans les yvelines 38% des
classes sont équipées d'un tableau vidéo
projecteur numérique à elancourt les
écoles élémentaires sont passés à l'ère
numérique depuis dix ans c'est bien
d'avoir
un écosystème une infrastructure en
pédagogie numérique
l encours et qu'ils soient de haute
qualité mais bien entendu le prof
restent au centre la pédagogie donc il
faut régulièrement échanger les
expériences renforcer la formation
continue des profs
parce que ça évolue très vite et ça
c'est très créatif ça rend les profs
très créatif 200 enseignants d'elancourt
de la verrière et de maurepas ont
participé à ce séminaire
en france le plan numérique est déployée
depuis la rentrée 2015
1800 écoles ont intégré cette année